Trascrizione: Beatrice Vecchiato
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
[Musica]
(Applausi)
Vorrei chiedervi di alzarvi,
ma fatelo solo se mi conoscete.
Magari perchè siamo amici, parenti
o forse in un qualche momento
della nostra vita
è capitato di incontrarci
e di interagire in qualche modo.
Potreste essere stati ad esempio
miei professori,
compagni di classe,
compagni di pallone, allenatori.
Alzatevi anche se siamo in contatto
in qualche social network
come Facebook, Twitter, LinkedIn
e magari lì ci è capitato di scambiarci
qualche commento o qualche messaggio.
Ecco, voi che vi siete alzati ora,
anche quelli più in fondo,
avete in realtà tutti
una stessa distanza da me
e quella distanza
è un grado di separazione.
Ma che cosa vuol dire?
Beh secondo la scienza delle reti,
ovvero quella disciplina
che unisce matematica
statistica, probabilità, fisica,
per studiare le strutture di connessione
che creiamo ogni giorno,
un grado di separazione vuol dire
che tra me e voi
esiste un unico ponte immaginario
che ci consente di interagire
ogni qualvolta lo vogliamo
e senza alcun tipo di intermediario.
Chi invece è seduto avrà
più gradi di separazione da me.
Ad esempio vorrei appunto chiedere
a chi al momento è seduto di alzarsi
se, per gli stessi motivi
che ho elencato in precedenza,
conosce almeno una delle persone
che al momento sono in piedi.
Fatelo.
Ecco, voi che vi siete alzati ora
avete invece due gradi
di separazione da me.
Ci sono, cioè, due ponti immaginari
che dovremmo attraversare
per entrare in relazione.
Come vedete, sto pian piano creando
una nuova idea di distanza,
è una distanza nascosta,
quasi impercettibile
che non si misura in kilometri,
metri, ore di volo,
ma tramite il numero di ponti immaginari
che dovremmo attraversare
per entrare in relazione.
Se ad esempio volessi sapere
chi dista da me 3 gradi di separazione,
non dovrei far altro
che chiedere di alzarsi
a chi al momento si trova in piedi
ma conosce almeno una delle persone
che al momento sono alzate.
Fatelo per favore.
Ecco, ora guardatevi un po’ attorno:
siete già quasi tutti in piedi.
Questo non mi stupisce,
anzi vi dirò di più,
se in questa stanza ci fosse stata
tutta la popolazione del mondo,
sono circa 7 miliardi
e 600 milioni di persone,
ed io avessi ripetuto questo esperimento
solamente altre tre volte,
si sarebbero alzati quasi tutti in piedi.
Si chiama teoria
dei sei gradi di separazione
e sostanzialmente ci dice che
chiunque al mondo,
ovunque egli sia, dovunque sia nato,
può essere messo in contatto
con qualsiasi altra persona
tramite una sequenza fatta
di non più di sei ponti relazionali.
Esisterà cioè quasi sicuramente
un amico dell’amico, dell’amico,
dell’amico di un vostro amico
che vi può mettere in contatto
con chiunque vogliate
sulla faccia della terra.
Ora so già che non ci credete tutti
quindi proviamo a fare
un veloce conto mentre vi risedete.
Provate a pensare che io abbia 45 amici,
non sono molti, generalmente
ne abbiamo ben di più
e provate a pensare che ora
ognuno di questi 45 amici
ne abbia a sua volta
altri 45 diversi tra loro
e provate a ripetere questo esperimento
per altre 4 volte.
Arriverete a contare 45
elevato alla 6 persone
e sono circa 8 miliardi
e 303 milioni di persone,
ben di più di quelle ora
sulla faccia della Terra.
È un numero enorme.
Un numero che, per come nasce, di fatto
ci colloca tutti molto più vicini,
è una sorta di Small World,
è così che viene chiamato
nella teoria delle reti.
Cioè un piccolo mondo
che magari farà sentire alcuni
di voi un po’ meno soli,
altri forse un po’ troppo oppressi.
Quello che ha trasmesso a me
è stato invece
un enorme fascino
per la matematica e la geometria
che questo risultato nasconde.
Se ci pensate è una geometria
che crea una nuova realtà parallela
in cui le nostre distanze
non sono più misurate in metri,
chilometri, ore di volo
ma tramite il numero di ponti relazionali,
cioè dei gradi di separazione,
che dovremmo attraversare
per entrare in contatto.
In realtà è proprio in questo spazio
che si muove la maggior parte
della vostra vita.
Proviamo a ragionarci.
Qual è, oggi, l’unico vincolo
che ci impedisce di interagire?
Voi al momento avete in tasca,
tutti di sicuro,
un oggetto, il vostro smartphone,
il quale contiene moltissime applicazioni
Whatsapp, Messenger, Skype,
chiamate, le email.
Tutte vi consentono di interagire
con chiunque vogliate
sulla faccia della terra
in millesimi di secondo.
A patto che...
A patto che la distanza tra voi
e questa persona,
sia un grado di separazione.
Se ci pensate oggi l’unico vincolo
che ci impedisce di interagire
è in realtà il più banale, il più semplice
però io direi,
il più romantico possibile:
cioè quello del conoscerci o meno.
Questo vale anche per me.
Sebbene infatti mi trovi qui
a pochi metri da voi,
in realtà non vi conosco tutti.
Anzi, alcuni di voi non li conosco affatto
o con altri ho molti gradi di separazione.
Questo significa che finora le nostre vite
non si sono ancora intersecate.
Potrebbero farlo tramite i contatti
che abbiamo in comune
ma potrebbero anche non farlo mai.
In questo caso, continueremo
a viaggiare su due binari paralleli
e per la storia della mia vita,
sebbene ora voi vi troviate
a pochi metri da me,
sareste un po’ come l’Australia
nello spazio delle relazioni,
sareste cioè estremamente lontani.
Ho invece molti amici in Inghilterra,
in Spagna, Brasile, Stati Uniti,
loro ora a si trovano a migliaia
di chilometri da me,
tuttavia la loro storia, la loro vita,
influenza continuamente la mia.
Un po’ come se in questo spazio
nascosto di relazioni
noi fossimo in realtà estremamente vicini.
Ecco che ora le distanze che separano me,
quel cerchio rosso che vedete,
da voi, che siete i cerchi azzurri ,
e dai miei amici, i cerchi verdi,
non rappresentano
la geometria della mia vita,
sono, anzi, una rappresentazione
estremamente instabile
di questa geometria.
Quello che in realtà vorrei fare
se mi venisse concesso di muovermi
senza vincoli in questo spazio
nascosto di relazioni,
sarebbe allontanarmi
da chi tra voi non conosco.
Un po’ come se fossimo tutti
delle particelle elettriche
con la stessa carica
che se avvicinate nello spazio
e non connesse
tendono a respingersi.
Quello che invece vorrei fare
è avvicinarmi man mano ai miei amici
con i quali sono connesso.
Come se quelle connessioni
fossero in realtà delle molle
che ci avvicinano nello spazio,
qualora fossimo lontani.
E vorrei continuare a muovermi
libero in questo spazio
fintanto che queste forze di attrazione
e repulsione non tenderanno ad annullarsi,
creando così una nuova dimensione
in cui le mie nuove posizioni
saranno coerenti
non più con le distanze fisiche,
ma con i gradi di separazione.
Ora quello che vi ho raccontato, in realtà
è proprio un algoritmo
che utilizziamo in statistica
per proiettare le tante reti
che oggi osserviamo
in un nuovo sistema di coordinate
capace di darci nuove informazioni,
informazioni nascoste riguardo alla rete.
Ora probabilmente molti di voi
troveranno questo metodo
e lo spazio che genera
estremamente astratto,
in realtà io ho una buona notizia per voi:
e cioè che senza accorgervene
voi ragionate
in questo spazio di relazioni
molte più volte rispetto a quanto pensate.
Provate a pensare
a quando prenotate un volo aereo:
una delle prime cose che fate,
dopo aver guardato il costo del biglietto,
è quella di vedere quanti sono gli scali
che separano il vostro aeroporto
di partenza da quello di arrivo,
per poi generalmente scegliere il volo
con meno scali possibile.
Ecco, voi
quando prendete questa decisione,
non state più ragionando nello spazio
fisico che separa gli aeroporti
tramite i chilometri o le ore di volo,
state in realtà ragionando nello
spazio nascosto nelle connessioni
in cui una distanza tra due aeroporti
non è più data dai chilometri
che li separano,
quanto invece dai gradi di separazione,
cioè dagli scali che li dividono.
È lo spazio
che partendo da questa immagine
che ha le vere posizioni degli aereoporti,
si sta creando in questo momento.
Come vedete sembra
una sorta di deriva dei continenti
che partendo dalla geometria vera
dello spazio fisico,
raggiunge una nuova geometria,
un nuovo sistema di coordinate,
coerenti con i gradi di separazione
tra gli aeroporti.
Guardate come gli aeroporti
più importanti, sono quelli più grossi,
raggiungano man mano il centro di gravità
di questo nuovo mondo.
Sono infatti quelli con il
maggior numero di voli,
quindi i più importanti nel garantire
la connessione all’interno di questa rete.
Viceversa, gli aeroporti più piccoli
sono separati da più gradi di separazione
e si muovono lentamente
verso la periferia.
Come vedete è una sorta
di deriva dei continenti
che ora crea un nuovo mondo,
un mondo a triangolo,
in cui l’America si avvicina
man mano all’Asia,
sono infatti anch’esse connesse da voli
tramite l’Oceano Pacifico,
e in cui l’Africa
si colloca tra Europa ed Asia
ed è in questo spazio, non nel planisfero,
che voi ragionate quando scegliete
il volo aereo in base agli scali.
Ora se questo video vi affascina,
a me quando l’ho creato
ha affascinato molto,
sono felice per voi.
In realtà, a me
che sono uno scienziato dei dati,
e mi piace plasmarli e manipolarli
per trasformare
informazioni in conoscenza,
quello che veramente mi affascina
è quando i nuovi spazi,
i nuovi sistemi di coordinate,
a cui siamo arrivati tramite
l’analisi dei dati di connessione,
d’un tratto svelano una nuova storia,
una storia nascosta,
che magari potevamo utilizzare
per migliorare le nostre.
Una di queste è la storia legata
a questa rete.
Questa è una rete di persone
apparentemente comuni
che magari avreste potuto
trovare sparse in modo casuale
in una qualche piazza,
senza alcun tipo di geometria.
Tuttavia, nello spazio nascosto
delle connessioni,
secondo questo sistema
di molle e particelle,
queste persone avrebbero iniziato
pian piano a muoversi,
avvicinandosi a coloro
alle quali sono connesse
ed allontanandosi da coloro
alle quali sono meno connesse.
Come vedete nello spazio
nascosto delle relazioni,
in questo nuovo sistema di coordinate,
ora notiamo una nuova storia.
È una storia di tre gruppi come li vedete:
due più piccoli ed uno più grande;
vengono chiamate comunità
nella teoria delle reti.
Quelle le due più piccole
che si uniscono quasi sempre
alla rete principale
passando per quel grosso cerchio rosso.
Ecco la sua dimensione,
così come quella delle altre persone
sono anch’esse state costruite
tramite metodi statistici
volti a valutare l’importanza
di ciascuna di quelle persone
nel garantire la coesione
e la trasmissione di informazioni
all’interno della rete.
Ad esempio, se questa fosse stata
una rete di contatti fisici tra persone
e a me venisse chiesto di manipolarla
per fare in modo che, ad esempio,
una certa malattia infettiva non
si diffonda facilmente attraverso la rete,
una delle prime cose che avrei fatto
sarebbe stato di prelevare
quel grosso cerchio rosso
ed in quel modo avrei quasi
spezzato la rete in due
facendo sì che la malattia infettiva
fosse isolata solo
a quella comunità in cui è nata.
Ecco, avrei fatto lo stesso
nella triste storia legata a questa rete.
Questa è una rete che
ha influenzato tutte le nostre.
Quel grosso cerchi rosso, infatti,
si chiama Mohamed Atta.
Ed è uno dei più noti terroristi
che insieme agli altri
che vedete colorati in rosso,
si schiantò sulla Torre Nord
del World Trade Center a New York
l’11 Settembre del 2001.
Gli altri cerchi colorati sono invece
gli attentatori che si schiantarono
negli altri aerei,
viceversa quelli grigi
sono tutti terroristi che fornirono
un qualche tipo di supporto,
in termini di denaro, informazioni
e addestramento aereo ai vari attentatori.
Questa è la loro rete terroristica
che venne pubblicata alcuni giorni dopo
in vari giornali e che fu parzialmente
ricostruita da alcuni ricercatori.
Come vi dicevo, sono connessioni
date da intercettazioni ambientali,
scambi di denaro, addestramento aereo,
alcune delle quali erano già disponibili
prima di quella drammatica giornata.
Tuttavia, come vedete,
quella drammatica giornata
era già parzialmente scritta
nelle coordinate di questa rete
che di fatto ci sta dicendo
di prelevare Mohamed Atta
per fare in modo
di far mancare agli attentatori
tutte le informazioni, il denaro,
che proveniva dagli altri.
Ecco, non so come sarebbe andata,
ma quello che di certo so
è che oggi abbiamo le armi
per combattere questo tipo di reti.
Non sono bombe, non sono caccia,
è matematica, statistica,
analisi dei dati, probabilità,
conoscenza in generale.
E un’ultima rete.
È la rete che per me è la più
importante di tutte,
ma anche la più misteriosa.
È il vostro cervello.
Ed in particolare la rete di fibre nervose
che connette le nostre diverse
regioni cerebrali
e consente all’informazione
di passare tra queste.
Ecco, raccogliere questo tipo
di dati è oggi diventato sempre più facile
grazie ai molti sviluppi che abbiamo fatto
in ambito di risonanza magnetica
e questo di fatto ha aperto
un nuovo universo,
ma dentro di noi.
È un universo che per me
è fatto di numeri, connessioni, forme
che si evolvono e plasmano di fatto
il nostro carattere
e la nostra personalità.
E sebbene la rete cerebrale,
ne vedete un esempio in questo video,
rispetti geometrie e proprietà comuni,
in realtà ogni singolo spazio relazionale
dietro ciascuno dei vostri cervelli
ha qualcosa di diverso.
È una sorta di variabilità matematica
che vi rende le persone che siete.
A me piace setacciare
questa variabilità matematica
per scoprire la firma
e le strutture comuni
e la firma della rete in molti fenomeni
che ad oggi non conosciamo
come Parkinson, Alzheimer,
memoria, intelligenza, apprendimento.
Ad esempio, in una recente ricerca
abbiamo dimostrato come
la chiave della creatività
non sia legata al vecchio mito
dell’emisfero destro o sinistro,
quanto invece alla capacità di creare
molte connessioni tra i due emisferi.
In questo modo nelle persone creative
le regioni cerebrali saranno
molto più vicine
nello spazio delle connessioni
rispetto a quanto non lo siano
nello spazio fisico.
Ecco, è con questo tipo di analisi
e con altre attraverso cui, spero,
apriremo le porte verso nuovi sviluppi
e nella scoperta di nuovi misteri
dietro il nostro cervello,
magari aprendo anche le porte
per ulteriori sviluppi
nell’intelligenza artificiale.
Per quanto mi riguarda
io ho un’unica certezza al momento:
e cioè che, quanto meno ad oggi,
esiste un unico super-computer
che, per capacità di apprendimento,
abilità nell’elaborare l’informazione,
quando anche questa è sconosciuta,
e per tempi di reazione,
batte qualsiasi altro super-computer
presente oggi sulla faccia della terra.
Secondo alcune analisi
ci vogliono mediamente
nove mesi per progettarlo,
poi 18 anni per insegnargli ad apprendere
e mediamente 79 per ucciderlo.
Ed è ciascuno di voi.
È l’essere umano,
e vediamo di non sprecarlo.
(Applausi)